I have boxes and boxes because
Claremont's work this one was also drawn
by a guy but this is a moet Frank Miller
that book was Wolverine number one and
little I beckoned you could not imagine
that you would ever see these characters
that interested that fascinating get the
attention of Hollywood but guess what
here we are the Wolverine
ladies and gentlemen welcome James
Mangold the director of the Wolverine
desaad yes yes how are you sir I'm good
I'm glad to be here it is great to see
you I have to say this is this is a pure
personal comment during the two of my
favorite movies three tendency to Yuma
and Copland's I mean some pretty great
movies thank you Jeff from tough guy
movies as this is some kind of movie
this is a tough guy movie I think one of
the things you and I set out to do was
with the space we had making a movie
just about located maybe there was
another one that set out to do that but
I did have a lot of other beauties in it
as well we had enough space here to make
a movie about Logan about inside I think
and about his journey of where he comes
from where he's headed
and then some of the characters that we
were introduced to in the comics that I
mentioned but then I've seen this film
it is great and it goes well well beyond
that it's also the local Japanese said
it gave me kind of I hope the license
change the tone a little bit to ratchet
things both up and down
meaning make the action I hope you agree
when you see it a little more intense a
little more physical you know Logan is
one of the one of the few superheroes
who can't jump tall buildings and sing
around can't change the atmosphere can't
fly out of our atmosphere Catco 747 down
but what he can do under the knock over
a bottle is he can use his claws and as
indestructible yes if incredible spinal
cord and a skeleton and you can deal and
it's like what is so important to me
about locating this is that we get
inside the anger and the rage that is
defined the character in comic books for
years but I don't think is that a chance
to be seen both in action and drama film
cell science activity we see Wolverine
this will be the sixth movie that he's
in I believe 90 pictures that includes
the 28 seconds yeah yeah but that's
pretty incredible if you think that they
were open straight by the same hand I
mean this man is going to the same
superior morning Christopher Reeve was
super manatees and you know London
I think Jeff he was is there's been some
roles in history I think wit as the man
with no name I think Sean Connery is the
first Bond I think I think Hugh Jackman
is in that strata I think that I think
that he encompasses both I think what
fans fall of Adam as he comes about the
physicality a role and also a part of
the role I think no matter what he does
in who hurts and who's cutting and who
is cursing you could see in his eyes as
something beyond that I also think Nick
just say how the cue is everybody
shape for movie before and I think he's
been in pretty bad shape before but what
you did before we started this after
being skinny bones and like this and
then bulking up for this movie I think
is pretty phenomenal and if you haven't
seen it the trailers it is gone
so do we have a video message from you a
video message we have Riera we have a
special thing we want to show okay let's
where do I stand when we're running this
show I tuck myself although I don't want
to get vertigo you should put on your 3d
glasses we should run this you guys want
to watch a Louisville great letter it
once again ladies and gentlemen no
record here no photography of any kind
at this time thank you I've made a few
movies but I can tell you what a
pleasure it is to be here and share this
with you it's been a two half year
journey with a great friend
bringing the Claremont Miller saag onto
the screen
I love these stories on my life I love
this world of this character all my life
and I hope when you see it in only a few
days you'll agree with me that my
partner and I get got some wherever he
hits the screen my partner went to speak
about some friend the last 12 years I
got the honor to make another film with
many years ago 12 years ago to be exact
and I think he said a pretty damn got
the job playing Wolverine over those 12
years mr. Hugh Jackman
oh it's good to see you guys all this is
honestly one of the greatest joys I ever
get in this business is to come here to
Hall H to thank you guys for allowing us
to do this thank you
q is so great see the character up there
it's so greasy Wolverine up there for
you I mean what can you tell us about a
journey the character has in this movie
is it's extraordinary change everything
Gmail I wanted to do about this movie
was to make sure that fans should see
the x-men movies first Wolverine movie
or for those who have it this is
something completely fresh completely
different obviously you guys know it
emanates from probably one of the most
famous comic book vaster japanese story
or samurai saga and 13 years ago I first
read that
in my trailer their comic book while
speaking my trailer
filming x-men one and I said the
Lawrence ala diet this is the movie we
need to make well 13 years later it's
here I think you get to understand way
more about the character that you've
ever seen before and as many of you who
have said to me on planes in the streets
various places around the world you
finally get to see to preserve the rage
in fall so I hope you enjoy it James
James I want to ask you a little bit we
have some more time what uh for you here
one of the things that you've got to do
in this film is we see a Wolverine who
does suffer who is in peril because he's
always healed before but things are a
little different in this movie right
well I don't to give anything away but I
think that one of the things that we
want to explore in this film that was
resonating through throughout Claremont
Miller and I think is a big issue for
any character that doesn't die it can't
than ever they can recover from any
injury or Logan's case I guess almost
any injury is is how do you go on living
what everyone you know and love fades
away what is that like you know we've
seen even in the first origins and in
the other expanded in art and we see
Logan to present through history and we
know for the comic books he's been
present through histories been here a
long time what's that like falling in
love losing losing the people you care
about watching people die and having to
start again unless we let's be honest
Logan is exactly the most socially adept
character we've ever seen in comic books
so when you lose the people you're
intimate with at some point you start to
withdraw and get low and it was our
decision when we decide where we to
start this film in relation
timeline of everything else that were to
begin when Logan's lost everybody
he's lost everybody the x-men Professor
X Jean Grey by his own hand affected so
when we find him in the Yukon is Clara
Peller begins we're finding also a
character who has retreated from
relationships with other living people
and the Oh bro Vince doesn't always go
well in superhero movies in Marvel
movies in general I mean the great
romances would be your Peter Parker and
Mary Jane or Gwen and of course Tony
Stark and until we start with Logan is
slow I mean Logan is always loved women
if there's one place thank you come on
ya know we talked about this right from
the beginning there was another thing
apart from the relationship of Jean Grey
I felt we could go way further with it
is is in the DNA of the comic book
series is that the saving grace and his
kryptonite is women so finally in this
movie there are four incredible female
characters there is as you saw briefly
there Jean Grey as fact you get to
understand probably more of that
relationship what it means to it but
there are three other great female
characters and personally and on behalf
of a brain that was a great thing
sometimes I don't like her make it a
Fellini film with my collection
chill out this is a this is a little
specific but the clothes look different
this time around we retooled them a
little just a little we did a couple
things I think you might notice the hair
is a little less nutty 80s rock the and
and and the claws we added we actually
hide survive
and we have drops I'm just looking at
detailed drawings in Clairemont Miller
and say there's blood work bevels and a
lot more flower stuff happening on these
plays the blades in the comic book were
more lethal from every direction and the
ones that I'd seen when they brought out
the ones that they use the previous
fields look like you can only get cut on
wet well we wanted to make the big big
cut two ways so three there's a lot of a
lot of puncture move to this bill
yeah Ultra Mobile is countrywoman Caesar
a lot of punchable - yes and some real
punch ones let me tell you I am very a
I'm trying to make a TV show I used to
watch going on one of you guys or no
danger danger Will Robinson I was a
hostage - suspect
okay sometimes when the cause I resemble
the robot
I have punctured my thighs my forehead
mystique couple had got it in the arm so
I'm a little dangerous with those claws
but so in the making odd and also in the
movie there's quite a lot of punch holes
but he's great I mean that you see some
of that fight when he goes uh what kind
of when career peace analysis look at
lots or even you replies and he won't
look at the rainy Road I'm sorry nice
nice nice sorry for the appropriately
there Morgan uglies the unfair in the
movie but the point is the point I was
making is there
between those two Hiroyuki is one of the
great swordsman and martial artists of
Japan a great action star there and you
and he deserves it he's amazing as
Canada films behind him in that fight
with long sword and short sword and claw
is something to behold thing is that the
film was also something me kneeling
beside the camera to behold in real life
disease to these two badasses were going
out of the blades and it was just about
staying out of each other's way
those were sharp you know
when the movie that comes out next year
with over here with that film Wolverine
will tie super head for number of movies
he's bended and it will be second only
to Batman who is the DC Comics character
I'm told a huge for you and you're those
other two I mean seriously played by
five different actors and this is your
character is going to tie Superman I
mean what is that like for you to kind
of try to get your head erect
it's very very difficult and it's
actually a thank you thank you I well
really I should be clapping you all
because when x-men one came out really
now on you how popular was going to be
and that's because no one understood the
power of the fans that are represented
here today and and I am forever grateful
to you all because
that was the first movie I ever did in
America I got the part almost 14 years
ago and I am loving playing more than
ever but I hoping I might be doing this
I did it last time I was here and I also
want to take things for granted and who
knows this may be the last time I am
here we already are not fishing for
anything I'm just saying who knows
what's going to happen but I have to
point out so many people for many many
decades before they pick up the mantle
and walk brain created nurtured and made
their all into what it is and some of
them are not here today there is one man
who is legally instead ugly weary men
whereas we went deadly leave me the
writer of hope one to edu 181 from his
fans head heart and hand que my career
so thank you thank you so much
that's every man but I never some of you
may know I was I by no means the first
to be cast as Wolverine someone else
already had the role unfortunately
couldn't do it I know from several act
that is Russell Crowe being one that the
power was often to a number I not only
did I come off the reserve inch I was
suddenly deep in the stands when that
will make this movie and when an actor
gets to come onto the field again
probably what I think is the greatest
role out there I'm not gonna let it go
easily
fantastic all right guys well ladies and
gentlemen where you guys take the
Wolverine guys interested
James James thank you so much for
joining us on 6 July 26 you thank you so
much thank you so much we'll see you
later okay hey sorry I've just got I
just got one little thing go ahead it's
not very often I'm here but listen one
of the great things there being in
movies like this these big blockbusters
playing a character this as a Florida B
is the opportunity to do other things
I've had great opportunities which this
role has offered me and particularly
being able to do smaller more indie
movies and I hope you know my chair - I
certainly hope Fox doesn't lie but I'd
like to take this opportunity to
reintroduce you to the director of a
movie about coming up there's a smaller
movie and I'd like to bring him out on
stage one takeoff ladies and gentlemen
Bryan Singer Ryan singer
hey hey hey you it fool
so they say your Fox I'm gonna surprise
panties like oh ok that's not right
anyway but thanks thanks so great to be
back here here it's been a few years
like a decade it's great to meet you on
stage reviews incredible and it's been a
really great journey more than Montreal
and making excellent Days of Future past
so I have everything so I'm very well um
because we're a year out a lot of the
visual effects
none of the visual effects really a
complete and many of them aren't even
works and we supplement you need to go
but I cut to get a little thing about
these film to show the local character
stuff I need to be night you did said
that it's in 3d so put your glasses on
and we really shot in 3d once again
ladies and gentlemen no recording or
photography of any kind at this time hey
wait okay
that guy looks very familiar to me did
you see that guy you see the game just
run right um this is an awful lot of
it's a really big table
I said I said this is a big-ass table
why just come back here
we're gonna show we will show it again
but we got something else
yes that's right
Brian come out the front and then we're
going to be joined by there's a couple
of producers who rejoice and a writer
agree sir you want to first I'd like to
bring on stage are you it's a very well
organized this is what happens when you
have a sequence a surprise I need to
look at the names first I like to
introduce a writer and co-producer of
the film Simon Kinberg I like injuries
producer of the film has been with every
excellent film with me for years Lauren
Shuler Donner are the producer hi farmer
I've worked with a number of years as
well here we have a whole bunch of
people you want me to do this I'm going
to let Jeff do the rest as I want to
forget somebody how many people you
think we got once one of the stage Oh
Marcy oh whatever
ladies and gentleman how about Ellen
Page Shawn Ashmore Anna Paquin Halle
Berry
James McAvoy
Jennifer lives
Nicolas wall Peter Dinklage
here's Lane joven the accident
I think Twitter just broke sweeter just
group guys why see Joyce around the
other side the tape
Oh everybody thank you for coming
okay I have to tell you I was here with
the Avengers window and this is bigger
we're going to start out with make sure
every gives you a chance to talk are so
forgive me if I just go quickly Evan how
are you sir nice to see you you know the
x-men universe is fascinating tell us a
little bit maybe about your character
what you're most excited about is like
voiceover right liquids over yet
fast and he's a bit of a spaz
he's a bit of a spaz good to know Peter
hurry sir
my name is Peter Dinklage and I play
volleyball Trask
it's novel to us realize we have all
these different franchise representative
you know we have Game of Thrones and
Hunger Games you know it just goes along
on a true star trek it's an amazing
panel this is pretty person you better
before it ever something like this I'm
having flashbacks yesterday
eggless for you what's it like Barnabas
has amazing Evensen head scary but thank
you for coming
Jennifer how are you I'm getting ham
your character I mean this is a chance
to find out more about her she's one of
the bigger mysteries really you know her
relationships and the way that she fits
in
they must be kind of exciting for you to
return it and find out where her story's
over
yeah absolutely yeah she's definitely
taken on two she's starting to find her
journey into Rebecca Romijn kind of the
later mystique that we know but is also
kind of still close to Charles and close
geographically yeah it's kind of her
journey as we having oh she's sure mr.
Fassbender harissa
you know he's hiding behind a podium
watching the footage that's why I bought
this what the hell was that way
I don't know becoming friends it's great
to be back you're fantastic to see so
many sort of your film enthusiasts comic
book enthusiasts crazy people it's nice
very excited to be back there testicle
James how are you I'm really good
I can't be in a room with this way
people without seen how you do in common
rizzoli Akuma comic-con as great as the
very first seventh of India I was in the
holes this morning waiting for my coffee
sure I'm as amazing the passion you guys
have service oceans Gables
yes mr. singer you know when you as the
director of this film you pulling
together a lot of disparate dates you
have two different sets of x-men your
very large cast obviously they're not
all in the same place at one time but
does that so is that an invigorating
challenge or is that something you have
to overcome i scheduling nightmare
so just to film i think but you know
it's great i actually like ensemble
films i started with the usual suspects
which is awesome so and I enjoy I enjoy
working with logic there's a lot of
interesting people to cut to when you're
making ensemble film and so I think the
more the merrier but I think the blend
of these two casts is extremely unique
and it's just a thrill for me because I
I was involved as a producer with the
excellent first class and story writer
but not as a director since opportunity
or with this incredible group of people
who have been enormous fans up for years
and to return with this family people
I'm right huh so it came quite easy
that's great
if you very quickly for you I mean you
talked a little bit about what's the
role me see but the ensemble feedback
oh man this is an embarrassment of
riches event look to work with the
people who are in the very first film I
ever did
that's incredible alone and then to work
with this new on this is about this is
two great movies and one I just like to
do one of these movies in my life I'll
be adding the factor with everybody here
this is something I'll never forget
all right you next two guys I have to
tell you Wow
you know
now this is uh this is nerd combo linear
right now around
softly in middle-earth represented in
actually
Patrick earlier today you're telling me
a little bit about the the esprit de
corps of the Starfleet crew that you
were part of compare this ensemble and
the energy and together we learned about
blessing several times today and to
experience a job as an actor with a
great group people who you not only
respect and admire but love to once in a
career is enviable but in my case
without that experience twice in the
career feels quite nice alright that's
lovely
Andy and we were talking earlier as well
how are you sir
you you would Patrick your work is not
done when you finish the work you know
no it is not I just like to say how
lovely it is to be back in California I
feel safe here now you've got rid of
Proposition 8
looking for a husband it's great to meet
you Michael
you get jealous
yep factually cute because Patrick and I
because of these movies and thank you
Brian
because assimil if your is on stage and
and in classical theater before me I got
to be part of this wonderful journey
we've now got even closer together and
so person forget it into place and
they're going to be on Broadway in the
order nobody wakes in Fergana a little
bit of Howard we'd say you can come to
see us on stay for single of the panel
previous choices hold women who kick out
kick ass and that applies to this panel
as well we have three Oscar winners on
this panel three of all women general
and the next two Halle and Anna Alan how
are you see you
you what do you see as your favorite
pick about storm she's such a wonderful
character such a classic character what
is it that really resonates with you I
you know what I've always loved about
storm is that why some thing I love
about her and something and hate about
her tell you what I love first what I
love about storm and death she's she's
like the earth-mother of the group and I
think that's part of my own personality
that resonates and what attracted me to
storm in the beginning she's usually the
calm cool voice of reason
besides being
she needs to be she's kind of the mom of
the groom what I hate about storm since
she never loved you guys probably know
more about the comic book than he
probably is she like asexual and
nobody's told me oh but I love was when
I got called to come back and play storm
again it didn't take me about a half a
second to say send me that way give that
costume I I'm in I love being a part of
this franchise and I love all the people
that are sitting up here the ones I've
known for 13 years as a new friend that
I've just made I couldn't think of a
better way to spend time working on a
movie with this great people and I'm so
glad Ryan singer is back hi how are you
that's such a great career journey you
know with True Blood and America all
that fantastic success and does that
make it even better to go back to a
character that created that for you you
know it's amazing
um I obviously a lot in the last 15
years of probably all of our lives but
it's incredibly exciting to get to come
back you know this was I got castles are
you know 17 you know so it's a it's
really really really amazing to you down
there Haven except berries so what's up
with the ice cream Bobby's back yeah no
I mean I think I can I can say the same
things everybody else for films and I
were teenagers we get to come back every
four or five years and as you rose
person as you grow around you get to
return to this amazing franchise with
amazing people so it's amazing backbone
friends great to meet new ones and I
think there's gonna be some really cool
stuff that people don't expect to see or
they've been possibly waiting to see
from a lot of these characters so it's
great it happened and Ellen
I was I was lucky enough to meet you
with on the set of exception I bet
everybody say how much you loved making
a movie of that scale special effects in
the visual ambition of it so I was
personally you must be very very excited
to be back in the universe first of all
I you know had never been on a set
remotely to that size or scale so sort
of blew my mind and was joining a group
of people who are already close but they
could not have been you know more lovely
and welcoming and so sweet and then
never did I expect to be back blind
Kitty Pryde again and just couldn't be
more excited right and in no more well
concerned are you and why don't you tell
us a little bit about your character
let's see that takes on its feature
some guy from the future and he fight
for survive
I thought of us absolutely that's well
it's one of those characters is an x-men
fan really Houston people always want to
see on the screen so it's just very
exciting the idea for the fans to see
that character come to life yeah we -
sure and then we're going to go to the
audience for some questions or read what
- question for the producers down there
what I can't see you guys I'm sorry what
what would you each see say is the most
important thing that this film had to
accomplish you're either in story orthey
or execution for a casting but I grew up
I think like most of you reading the
comics and so being lowly the original
stories is the most important thing to
us and like you said this is an
embarrassment of riches of actors so the
same way it's surreal and cool for you
to see all these guys up here
I think it's surreal to go for us to on
set every day so it's really about the
original books the original stories and
just trying to endure that as best we
can it's nicely Lauren how are you - say
hello hello thank you guys for coming
for showing up and supporting our films
you know we share your love thank you
really
it's only as the comics were written so
well that we were able to spin these
stories but I gotta say that starting
with the first
one and getting to this one for me
personally to see this cast mixed
together with Bryan Singer it just
impacts my crying silently and I think I
think for for all of us probably the
most amazing opportunity offers is in 25
years of making movies for me personally
I've never seen a better cast assembled
in anything at any time and it's matched
by a story thanks to Simon and the
underlining comic book that I think is
worthy of the cast and underpriced
Bryan's stewardship so it's amazing
opportunity for all of us are very
grateful and excited to share with you
yeah we could we're going to take a
couple questions but there's not a lot
of plot stuff that can be discussed
probably and then maybe watch the
footage to get where yes i guess i've
couple three questions okay
they're saving William I feel really bad
for asking this because you've given me
and all of us so much right now there's
so many of you
so since the x-men universe is expanding
now like the Avengers universe I can ask
that question I promise um now that
you're combining the x-men movies that
have been made and are going forward
with future movies is there anywhere
so I guess that's a question is Deadpool
possible and it was possible not this
particular formula but anything is
possible what it really occurred does it
the excellent universe everything is
large if you really look at it as the
remaining Marvel Universe the DC
Universe and I think you've carefully
explore movie by movie much like
Marvel's done and DC is do I think
there's a lot of room for growing and
expanding expanding the film Canon for
four excellent so yeah I mean some
people could have their own movies find
movies all those things are obviously
possible so you see them working is that
a yes or no tell you know I say yes
right sir
whatever that means yeah I mean yo Q I
had a quick question for you you know
there's an actor over the Marvel Studios
universe's Doug hypo named Robert Downey
jr. and I was wondering I was Larry
David he's an actor who's a robber
nothing
hey I'll tell you later okay but I was
just wondering you know if it will
breathe Iron Man to get along kind of
met each other would that be like a can
opener situation or when we go hold up
there's no walk away I don't want to be
responsible and take a gun I'm and that
you're not above okay but like fine fine
with that I regularly feds had some kind
of a big mashup you know when I was
young in Australia we had a cartoon on
TV that had two superheroes in the Hall
of Doom and now we're all in together
that was 8:30 Saturday morning for me
every week I'm all for it but it's
people way about me when they decide I
want something we're going to take
another question
hi what's your name hi my name is Henry
Kenna and we'll every second getting out
in the cold with a wet grass is really
worded and like every
you're smoking wet grass yeah we went
cold doesn't matter anymore so so my
question is if you could pick off to me
another x-men who would you choose and
why if you could do another excellent
film sorry no I think I could pick
another character to me we can think
about my character is I can you that's
it anyway nobody does a question for
that excellent hey what's your question
there we go oh they have a nice curtsy
like okay my god hi my name is Keira and
I actually have been questions for Hugh
Jackman I was kind of curious he's done
several standalone
movies and these movies I just wanted
house is different when you're preparing
for the role and you can have your group
but you're not going to have your group
is it different is one easier than
harder a groove group grip if I like the
idea of the room yet no the Wolverine
groove really is the same and if you
come to my house host Saturday night's
I'm grooving as well great so the same
you know it's a preparation no different
in a Wolverine is Wolverine and and
every movie in a way is ensemble but
let's be honest look at this cannot look
at what I'm turning up to work every day
not any being able to work in the future
part of the movie but also look in the
past with it on someone ever get to work
with with the man who gave me the job
that is defined by career so it is it
not every day I'm grateful and I thank
my lucky stars especially alright we've
got another question from another member
of the audience here is o H comic
audition hi um my name is Adela I'm from
Melbourne Australia yeah
um so yeah this is just blowing my mind
expecting here so sorry oh my god the
guy from Australia is gonna be in or
whatever
totally my 15 hour flight
so our Egyptian maybe can but I was
wondering if we're ever going to see a
gambit brave exploring all options at
the moment right I'm ganna video
suggestions making notes suggestions hit
me up on Twitter some time I'm really
jealous is that anybody from show in
here
I'm entirely on my own somebody said am
i right it's been a difficult as we all
know is like popping up in different
places I don't know what you can say
about is there anything is it
yeah well Quicksilver was always a part
of the story as we're developing it I
the casting took a while to find the
right actor for this role and then huge
fan of Evanston so making that work was
really fantastic I don't I can't speak
to the Avengers but Lee but it's a
character that our character exists
we'll talk about character you haven't
even described the character oh yes he
said he's very fast it's very fast it's
quick I don't know he's just fast he
just talks quick he moves quick
everybody is very slow compared to him
it's like it's like he's always at an
ATM waiting for the bastard if I'm gonna
finish it's always kind of like that
he's got excellent genes
is it going to be constant for the blue
custom it's going to be a 70s constant
okay I did you know I grew up as I get
into 70s and I had forgotten how hideous
some of the clothing was back now these
guys sorry
but these guys I look incredible in this
show but they make it look quite good
and but um yeah
Peter kickflip looks like my father's
about the dinkledge near that handsome
oh by the way it's not a way it's like
it's real hair this hair thinks he is
asking how's the wig that's it that's
really it just can comb like that oh I
got a sweet Tom Selleck mustache
how's it going what's your name hi my
name is Gary and my question is for Hugh
Jackman um Hugh Jackman you starred in
both musicals and big-budget films what
unique characteristics do you bring to
each of the different mediums
grooviest scream oh I can tell you there
won't be any scene useful brain I can
tell you that right now really you
really want more in the musical
I'm gonna spice up
I'm going to dice up
it's a thing if your question I don't
know my name every every film requires a
I feel like I can't answer this
seriously now but but if everything
everything requires something different
it's just so we need to play a character
seven times and you know and so creates
Viva I just remembered
you know this morning it was sad me all
the time and it's my fault I'm here at
Comic Con they say all the time you
cannot walk around you know San Diego as
you jack but I did in fact this morning
I got dressed up at my full Wolverine
costume no one person stopped me one guy
goes yeah and I said well way too tall
okay do you want to say hi hello hey she
was on point
she's our the story uncle hi my name is
Audrey I just wanted to let you know
that I but I spent since I was a little
girl and it's such an honor meter out
with you guys oh uh true just to have
the cast of the original hex man the new
Ice Man O'War raid like this is like the
best night of my life I was my question
if you guys are paying for sure yeah
like who's your favorite character in a
few words
who's your favorite character down not
necessarily the person that you're
playing you're stuck doing some of that
games and I say Wolverine very much
mystique
the cartoons of what I loved beasts in
the cartoons right off Magneto
but I'm storm I call mystique at camp it
because I thought he's got a crazy
accent and maybe if people can
understand them they'll be able to
understand me yeah
Professor X sorry
cuz he's in charge I'm Chuck I'd love to
play Wolverine one day I on 50 times
about it up no uh table I would like to
play any female character in any x-men
movie because then I might send the
chance of winning an Academy Award
if I can't the younger Magneto
I like to growing some my angel I'd like
to give a run at mystique Wolverine
unless Brooke could fly that'd be nice
and then I'm sick
what mysteries
I think mistake for me because she can
be all these guys Jean Grey has to be
Wolverine to me fast because we know
what we're going to no worry we are
going to show it again the first help me
help me tell these people how awesome
sauce it is it's even on the stage
all right